polly polytopia is my current obsession
like
thank you for passing on your obsession
to me are you playing now yeah i'm
playing now we gotta have a game but i'm
terrible and i enjoy playing terribly i
don't want to have a game because that's
going to pull me into your monster of of
like competitive play it's important
i'm enjoying playing on the
i can't
you just do that you just do the points
thing you know against the bots yeah i
guess the bots and i can't even do the
uh uh there's like a hard one and
there's a very that's crazy yeah that's
crazy i can't i don't even enjoy the
hard one the crazy i really don't enjoy
because it's intense you have to
constantly try to win as opposed to
enjoy building a little world and
yeah no no no there's no time for
exploration in polytechnic you gotta get
well when once you graduate from the
crazies then you can come play the
graduate from the crazy yeah so in order
to be able to play a decent game against
like
you know our group um you'll need to be
you'll need to be consistently winning
like 90 of games against 15 crazy bots
yeah
and you'll be able to like there'll be i
could i could teach you it within a day
honestly um
how to be the crazies how to be the
crazies and then and then you'll be
ready for the big leagues generalizes uh
to more than just polotopia
you